und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und marietas lomka guten Abend ein
großkrieg in Europa eine wohl nicht mal
bedingt abwehrbereite Bundeswehr eine
Zeitenwende die bislang nur auf dem
Papier steht und Ende der Woche gibt es
wieder ein großes Treffen der Ukraine
Unterstützer in Ramstein da gilt das
Farbe zu bekennen Stichwort Kampfpanzer
wer immer Ministerin Lambrecht nachfolgt
wird sich also keine lange
Einarbeitungszeit leisten können Sie
selbst kleidete ihren Abgang heute in
ihr Dürre Worte unterm Strich stand die
Botschaft die Medien waren schuld in
gewisser Weise passt das zu einer
Ministerin die vor allem mit
kommunikationsdefiziten und missglückten
Auftritten in Verbindung gebracht wird
Thomas Reichert über die Chronik eines
angekündigten Rücktritts
als Olaf Scholz vor gut einem Jahr seine
SPD-Minister vorstellt bekommt eine
besonders
üppige Vorschusslorbeeren Christine
Lambrecht die Frauen und Männer in der
Bundeswehr haben auch verdient dass
jemand vorne ansteht im Ministerium der
sich für sie einsetzte ein Herz für sie
hat und dafür sorgt dass sie gut
ausgestattet werden aber die es auch
kann tatsächlich musste sich Lamprecht
in ihrer kurzen Amtszeit immer gegen den
Eindruck wären dass sie es nicht konnte
oder nicht können wollte dass sie ihn an
nie richtig ankam
ein schönes Wochenende wäre es halt
wünscht Lambrecht am Freitagnachmittag
und weiß wohl dass Sie es nicht haben
wird kurz darauf melden Medien dass sie
zurücktreten werde doch erst am Montag
ein paar Dürre Worte Schultern ihrem
scheiter ist nicht sie selbst ist sind
die Medien die monatelange mediale
Fokussierung auf meine Person lässt eine
sachliche Berichterstattung und
Diskussion über die Soldatinnen und
Soldaten die Bundeswehr und
sicherheitspolitische Weichenstellungen
im Interesse der Bürgerinnen und Bürger
Deutschlands kaum zu glauben dass auch
der Rücktritt zeigt dass sie zu keinem
Zeitpunkt ein richtiges Verhältnis zu
dem Amt gefunden hat die Inhaberin der
befehlsson Kommando Gewalt muss immer
erst die Soldatinnen und Soldaten und
den Auftrag sehen den sie zu verrichten
haben und nicht ihre eigene
Befindlichkeit doch es ging viel zu viel
und Privates um ihren Sohn den sie im
Helikopter mit Namen um ein missglücktes
Silvester Video Lambrecht war Ministerin
für Selbstverteidigung dabei hätte sie
sie eigentlich Geschichte schreiben
können mit dem 100 Milliarden
Sondervermögen mit der Sanierung einer
maroden Bundeswehr sie aber verlor sich
im Kleinklein die Fokussierung auf
Nebensächlichkeiten kommt daher dass in
der Hauptsache nichts an Erfolgen zu
melden war also die großen Dinge
Reformen der Streitkräfte das alles ist
ja nicht passiert das steht noch bevor
und jetzt haben wir praktisch einen
verlorenes Jahr die Schwäche der
Ministerin wurde zur Schwäche des
Ministeriums zunehmend bestimmte das
Kanzleramt z.B welche Waffen die
Bundeswehr an die Ukraine abzugeben habe
die lange in der Bundeswehr ist prekär
das war sie vor Kriegsbeginn Stichwort
Russland Ukraine und sie ist es jetzt
erst recht warum einerseits natürlich
die Unmengen an ausrüstungsabgaben
zurecht an die Ukraine aber es kommt
eben zu wenig Gerät nach Kanzler Scholz
dank Lamprecht heute zur Nachfolge Frage
von ihm nur so viel er weiß es aber er
sagt es noch nicht
das Bundesministerium der Verteidigung
die Bundeswehr aber alle die sich um die
Landesverteidigung in unserem Land
bemühen haben verdient dass das schnell
geklärt wird ich weiß wie es aus meiner
Sicht weitergehen soll und wir werden
das dann auch rechtzeitig bekannt geben
es klingt wie damals als er Lamprecht
vorstellte doch was die Bundeswehr
verdient und bekommt daran hängt
spätestens jetzt auf das politische
Kapital von Olaf Scholz
Theo call in Berlin sehr eilig scheint
es Olaf Scholz in diese Angelegenheit ja
irgendwie nicht zu haben ja in der Tat
also wenn es stimmt was die
spiegelkollegen heute Abend berichten
dass der Kanzler schon am 3 Januar über
den Rücktritt informiert war dann hätte
er war nicht reichlich Zeit gehabt für
eine geräuschlose und hier auch gut
vorbereitende Nachfolge Lösung aber
selbst wenn er weniger Zeit hatte nach
dem Silvester Video war doch politisch
erkennbar dass eine Alternative
gebraucht werden würde dass der Kanzler
seit Tagen diese personelle nebenan
nebelwanderung in seinem wichtigsten
Ressort zugelassen hatte das ist
entweder ein politisches Versäumnis oder
es zeigt wie schwierig die neue
Besetzung ist oder beides die sehr
schadet denn diese ganze
also ich glaube sie schlägt den
mehrfacher Hinsicht direkt auf ihn durch
Olaf Scholz hat Christine Lambrecht
gewollt und zur Verteidigungsministerin
gemacht trotz fachlicher Unkenntnis das
war schon in normalen Zeiten ein Risiko
in den Anforderungen von Krieg und
zeitenwände aber ist die Personalien
noch einmal wichtiger geworden für das
Gelingen der ganzen ampelregierung
lambrechts fehlende Entschlossenheit wir
haben es eben gehört zur Reform der
Bundeswehr ihre zögerlichen
Materialbestellungen vieles mehr das
verbindet sich auch mit ihrem Chef der
sie ja noch vor kurzem als erstklassige
Verteidigungsministerin gelobt hat und
darf jetzt zumindestens bis morgen
mindestens über Nachfolger
Nachfolgerinnen noch spekuliert werden
die müssen ja auch das
Anforderungsprofil mit sich bringen
ja also wenn man sich den
Ausschreibungstext einer Stellenanzeige
anschauen würde was da gefordert ist
dann ist es ein Mensch mit politischem
Schwergewicht Bundeswehr Kenntnis und
auch Neigung durchsetzungsstark
idealerweise eine Frau Namen werden ja
reichlich genannt keiner der genannten
passt aber politisch perfekt die
Minister Heil oder Schmidt würden beide
große Löcher im Machtgefüge der Ampel
reißen so wie er auch Klingbeil an der
spd-partei Spitze und alle drei sind
Männer die genannten Frauen haben
militärische Kenntnisse würden aber die
ähm würden die versprochene Parität
erhalten aber es fehlt ihnen an
Führungserfahrung großer Institutionen
und nicht zu vergessen die gebotene
Bedingungen dieser Stelle sind für alle
gleich unattraktiv ein Kaltstart ohne
Schonfrist das ganze auf einem
Schleudersitz mit langer Tradition
Karrieren zu können also wir dürfen
gespannt sein in der Tat danke schön
ja wer immer danachfolger oder
Nachfolgerin wird das wissen wir noch
nicht aber mit welchen inhaltlichen
Herausforderungen man in diesem Amt ist
zu tun hat das wissen wir schon sehr
viel besser und darüber wollen wir mit
Thomas Wiegold sprechen Journalist und
Militärexperte sehr profunder Kenner der
Bundeswehr guten Abend Herr Wiegold
guten Abend was ist denn ihre
Einschätzung nach die größte Baustelle
das Projekt Zeitenwende
die Frage wie man das definieren will
also wenn wir uns daran erinnern der
Chef des deutschen Heeres hat kurz nach
Beginn der russischen Angriffskrieges
gesagt das deutsche Jahr steht blank da
und das hat sich so viel nicht geändert
seitdem im Gegenteil die Bundeswehr hat
ja Material abgegeben an die Ukraine hat
es nicht ersetzt bekommen es eher noch
schlimmer geworden aber da gibt es ja
jetzt die 100 Milliarden Sondervermögen
wie viel ist davon denn schon bei der
Truppe angekommen
ziemlich genau gar nichts na gut recht
wenig für dieses Sondervermögen ist
bisher
bewilligt worden der Kauf der F35
Kampfflugzeuge aus den USA das werden an
die 10 Milliarden und das ist ein
wichtiger Punkt moderne digitale
Funkgeräte die sind aber erstmal
bestellt bis die ankommen wird auch noch
ein bisschen dauern alles andere ist
noch nicht mal bestellt worden und das
ist etwas was viele in der Bundeswehr
aufregt Stichwort zum Beispiel Munition
da ist klar für 10 manche sagen 20
Milliarden Euro müssen die
Munitionsvorräte aufgefüllt werden aber
auch da gibt es noch keine Bestellung da
sie gerade von Munition sprechen wie man
die Ukraine die verfeuern ja jeden Tag
unglaublich viel ich glaube irgendwo mal
eine Zahl gesehen ungefähr so viel wie
wir in einem halben Jahr produzieren
also da müssen wir jetzt eigentlich
Rüstungsfirmen quasi aus dem Boden
sprießen um überhaupt diese dieses
munitionsthema zu bewältigen
das tun sie auch aber die Bestellung
kommen aus den Nachbarländern zum
Beispiel war der größte genehmigte
Rüstungsexport im vergangenen Jahr etwa
zwei Milliarden Euro für die Niederlande
die haben nämlich in Deutschland
Munition bestellt die Bundeswehr konnte
durfte hat jedenfalls nicht längst nicht
in den Maßeinheit gar nicht bestellt
warum eigentlich nicht ist dass dieses
berühmte Beschaffungswesens Problem oder
woran hängt das
es hängt sehr viel mit diesen ganzen
Prozessen zusammen die nötig sind damit
Geld auch in Bewegung gesetzt werden
kann damit was eingekauft werden kann
also das Sondervermögen hat ja der
Kanzler Ende Februar angekündigt im
Sommer wurde es bewilligt und erst im
November hat der Haushaltsausschuss
angefangen bestimmte Gelder daraus
freizugeben für konkrete Projekte diese
ganzen Abläufe zeigen dass ich in den
Prozessen nicht viel geändert hat auch
wenn Krieg in Europa herrscht der
Bundeskanzler hatte ja auch im Verband
im Verbund mit diesem Zeitenwende Rede
auch gesagt die Bundeswehr sollte zur
größten konventionellen Armee und der am
besten ausgestatteten Streitkraft der
NATO in Europa werden das klingt jetzt
so als seien wir davon noch sehr weit
entfernt und eine fast unmögliche
Aufgabe an die Lambrecht Nachfolger
Nachfolgerin
naja diese Ansage des Kanzlers ist wenn
man auf das Nachbarland Polen schaut
eigentlich nicht zu erfüllen die haben
in sehr großen Stil bestellt sowohl in
den USA als auch in Südkorea nicht in
Deutschland übrigens also dass die
Bundeswehr sich daran tastet an diesen
Spitzenplatz das wird einige Zeit dauern
und auch ein Nachfolger einen
Nachfolgerin von Lambrecht wird die
nächste vier Jahre also den Rest der
Legislaturperiode damit verbringen die
Baustellen zu bearbeiten aber nicht die
größte Streitmacht in Europa zu schaffen
es geht ja nicht nur um größer sondern
auch um ein ganz andere Aufgabe weil wir
sind ja jetzt im Prinzip gehen wir ja
weg von naja wir schicken Soldaten nach
Afghanistan oder sonst wo in die Ferne
sondern eigentlich kennt man ja wieder
zurück in das was man noch aus kalten
Kriegszeiten kann also
Landesverteidigung in großen Stil
ja man könnte auch sagen in das wofür
die Bundeswehr eigentlich nicht mal
geschaffen wurde
Landesverteidigung die inzwischen ja
auch immer Verteidigung des
bündnisgebietes und ja das ist
eigentlich das
auffällige die Bundeswehr ist in den
vergangenen Jahrzehnten umgebaut worden
zu dieser Streitmacht die auf geplante
Auslandseinsätze geht nicht mehr eine
die innerhalb kurzer Zeit zur
Verteidigung des bündnisgebiets und des
Landes zur Verfügung stellt und dieser
zurückbau dieser erneute Umbau der hat
schon vor Lambrecht begonnen und der
wird auch lange nach Lambrecht
fortgesetzt also schwierige Aufgaben an
schwieriges Ministerium für das Gespräch
gerne
das Gespräch haben wir vor einer Stunde
geführt ja Stichwort Wehrhaftigkeit
Gefährdungen im Innern gibt es ja auch
noch durch Extremisten Terroristen
verschiedener Couleur in
Nordrhein-Westfalen ist man da wo
möglich um die Jahreswende nur knapp
einer Katastrophe entgangen und wieder
einmal war es ein ausländischer
Geheimdienst im konkreten Fall das
amerikanische FBI dass die deutschen
Sicherheitsbehörden auf die Spur brachte
was hatten die Brüder aus Castrop-Rauxel
vor und warum konnten sie gemeinsam
mutmaßliche Anschlagspläne schmieden
während einer der beiden als
verurteilter Straftäter unter
behördenaufsicht stand
auch darum ging es heute in einer
Sondersitzung des Landtags Dorthe Färber
berichtet
dieser Polizeieinsatz in Castrop-Rauxel
hat vermutlich einen Terroranschlag
verhindert das wird immer klarer in der
Nacht zum 8 Januar werden hier zwei
Brüder aus ihrer Hand festgenommen sie
stehen im Verdacht ein islamistischen
Anschlag zu planen mit hochgiftigen
Substanzen Rizin oder Cyanid aber Gift
wird nicht gefunden bei einer erneuten
Durchsuchung vergangenen Donnerstag
wurden dann wohl Substanzen gefunden
es sind die bisherigen
durchsuchungsobjekte nochmals ohne
besondere Sicherungsvorkehrungen wie zum
Beispiel spezielle Schutzanzüge
durchgeführt worden hierbei konnten
weitere Beweismittel sichergestellt
werden deren Untersuchung dauert an die
Nachricht platzt am Morgen in die
Sitzung des Rechtsausschusses im
nordrhein-westfälischen Landtag da
erfahren die Abgeordneten noch dass das
Bundeskriminalamt schon am 30 dezember
von einem ausländischen Geheimdienst den
Hinweis auf die Anschlagspläne bekam in
der Silvester Nacht sollte eine größere
Menschenmenge angegriffen werden eine
Woche später trifft die Polizei in
Nordrhein-Westfalen zu die
Generalstaatsanwaltschaft Düsseldorf hat
am 7 januar von dem Verdacht in den es
hier geht erfahren und hat umgehend ein
Durchsuchungsbeschluss erwirkt und
diesen am selben Tag vollstreckt was
geschah mit den Informationen des
Bundeskriminalamts vom 30 Dezember diese
Frage bleibt offen und noch etwas warum
durfte der Jüngere Verdächtige der 2019
wegen versuchten Mordes zu sieben Jahren
Haft und Unterbringung in einer
Entzugsanstalt verurteilt worden war
überhaupt bei seinem Bruder übernachten
wir haben erfahren dass er ganz viele
Ausgänge hatte und mit seinem Bruder
Kontakt haben konnte und nach den
jetzigen Meldungen die wir haben dass er
möglicherweise auch eine treibe Kraft
sein soll muss ich sagen hier sind wir
haarscharf an einer Katastrophe
Nordrhein-Westfalen vorbei gegangen die
Ermittlungen im Fall Castrop-Rauxel
dauern an und die Debatte um die Frage
wie Behörden mit dem Terrorverdacht
umgegangen sind
mit dem Krieg gegen die Ukraine geht es
jetzt in den Nachrichten weiter eins ein
neues luftwaffenmanöver von russischen
und belarussischen Truppen schürt in der
Ukraine die Sorge für eine Offensive von
Belarus aus nach Angaben des
belarussischen Verteidigungsministeriums
haben die Übungen wie angekündigt heute
Morgen begonnen in der ukrainischen
Großstadt nephros sind nach dem schweren
russischen raketentreffer vor zwei Tagen
in einem Hochhaus weiter Rettungskräfte
im Einsatz mittlerweile konnten sie 40
Menschen nur noch tot aus den Trümmern
Bergen laut den örtlichen Behörden
werden immer noch Dutzende Menschen
vermisst
bundesaußenministerin baerbock will die
russische Führung für diesen
Angriffskrieg juristisch zur
Rechenschaft ziehen vor einem neuartigen
Sondertribunal dafür sprach sie sich bei
einer Rede an der Akademie für
Völkerrecht in Den Haag aus man brauche
die klare Botschaft an die russische
Führung und damit auch an alle anderen
in der Welt dass ein Angriffskrieg nicht
ungestraft bleibe
in Afghanistan hatten mehrere
Hilfsorganisationen ihre Arbeit
ausgesetzt nachdem die Taliban vor rund
drei Wochen afghanischen Frauen eine
Mitarbeit verboten hatten jetzt werden
einzelne Projekte wieder aufgenommen die
Hilfsorganisation Save the Children
teilte mit sie werde dort wieder aktiv
wo verlässliche Zusagen für eine sichere
Rückkehr der MitarbeiterInnen gegeben
wurden es sei ein Projekte in den
Bereichen Gesundheit Ernährung und
Bildung
die Zahl der Organspender in Deutschland
ist im vergangenen Jahr weiter
zurückgegangen umfasst sieben Prozent
nach Zahlen der Deutschen Stiftung
Organtransplantation demnach spendeten
869 Menschen nach ihrem Tod ein oder
mehrere Organe
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach
sprach sich angesichts des Rückgangs für
eine Reform aus er sagte der dpa der
Bundestag sollte einen erneuten Anlauf
nehmen über die Widerspruchslösung
abzustimmen sie sieht jeden zunächst als
Spende an außer man widerspricht
die Räumung des rheinischen
braunkohleorts lutterath ist
abgeschlossen sechs Tage hatte der
Polizeieinsatz gedauert am Mittag
verließen die letzten beiden Aktivisten
den selbst gegrabenen unterirdischen
Tunnel freiwillig sie hatten sich dort
tagelang verschanzt zur weiteren
Protesten gegen den Braunkohleabbau kam
es in der Umgebung von lützerath
darunter eine baggerbesetzung und eine
Straßenblockade mehrere Demonstranten
darunter zwei im Rollstuhl Seiten sich
von einer Autobahnbrücke ab und störten
den Verkehr
wer vom Ausland nach Palermo fliegt
landet auf dem internationalen Flughafen
der nach den Richtern Falcone und
borselino genannt ist den beiden
berühmtesten Mafia Jägern Italiens die
für ihre Arbeit mit dem Leben bezahlen
eine ständige Erinnerung kann das
Treiben der Mafia in Italien
Falcone hatte die Hoffnung dass es mit
diesem Spuk irgendwann vorbei sein werde
die Mafia sei ein menschliches Phänomen
sagte er und jedes menschliche Phänomen
habe irgendwann ein Ende
seine Ermordung ist über 30 Jahre her
und so lange schon suchten die Behörden
vergeblich nach einem der Cosa Nostra
Bosse die daran mutmaßlich beteiligt
waren jetzt ging er ihnen ins Netz dank
einem menschlichen Phänomen auch Mafiosi
müssen zum Arzt Andreas Postel Bericht
als sich die Nachricht von seiner
Festnahme auf den straßenpalermos herum
spricht gibt es spontan Applaus
Schulterklopfen für die karabinieri und
Tränen der Erleichterung am Morgen
greifen Spezialeinheiten zu und
verhaften den meistgesuchten Mafia Boss
Italiens bei einem Krankenhausbesuch
in dieser Privatklinik ließ sich der
60-Jährige unter falschem Namen wegen
einer Krebserkrankung behandeln als die
Beamten ihn stillen gesteht er seine
wahre Identität er ist es Matteo Messina
de naro ja
wir haben den letzten Strategen der
Massaker von 1992/93 festgenommen das
war eine Schuld die die Republik
gegenüber den Opfern jener Jahre hatte
und diese Schuld ist mit dem heutigen
Tag teilweise beglichen das ist das
wichtigste für uns
ein sensationeller Schlag gegen die
kosanostra so bedeutsam dass Italiens
Ministerpräsidentin Georgia Meloni
sofort nach Palermo kommt
ihr zeigt sich einen entschlossenes
Italien das in diesem Kampf nicht
aufgegeben hat weil es stärker ist als
die Mafia das ist eine wichtige
Botschaft für unsere Glaubwürdigkeit und
den Stolz unserer Nation der jetzt
gefasste Mafia Boss war ein Abwesenheit
wegen Mordes zu lebenslange Haft
verurteilt worden er wird
mitverantwortlich gemacht für die
Ermordung der berühmten darf ja Jäger
Falcone und bosselino vor 30 Jahren am
23 mai 1992 stirbt richtete Giovanni
Falcone durch eine gewaltige
Sprengladung wenige Wochen später wird
auch Paolo bosselino brutal ermordet
eine Zäsur für Italien
doch wie konnte der meistgesuchte
kriminelle des Landes 30 Jahre auf
freiem Fuß bleiben zu lange schon
bestehe ein Klima der Angst sagt uns
einer der sich damit auskennt
nisse verlassen nie ihre wir niemals den
riskante Bewegungen hinterlassen Spuren
stattdessen gibt es in ihrem Land ihrem
Territorium den maximalen Schutz dort wo
jeder der mit der Polizei Zusammenarbeit
bestraft wird und wo jeder der sich
einschleust und seltsame Fragen stellt
sofort identifiziert wird dass der König
der Kosa nostra gefasst werden konnte
hänge nicht nur mit seiner Erkrankung
zusammen sondern zeige auch dass die
cousinastra schwer angeschlagen sei die
große Frage wird nun sein ob Mateo
Messina denaro jetzt mit den Behörden
kooperiert oder schweigt da der letzte
große Boss der sizilianischen kasanostra
Geheimnisse über Verbrechen und
Verstrickungen zwischen Politik und
Mafia mit sich trägt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und jetzt geht es bei dir noch mal
weiter Hans zum nächsten anderen Blick
auf die Weltwirtschaft ja im
schweizerischen Davos beginnt dass
diesjährige
Weltwirtschaftsforum in einer Zeit mit
gleich mehreren Krisen auf einmal wie
dem Ukraine Krieg oder der
corona-pandemie was sind in dieser
besonderen Zeit die Erwartungen an das
Weltwirtschaftsforum ja auch dieses Mal
geht es um die ganz großen Fragen wie
die Krisen dieser Welt lösen Kriege
Hunger Armut auch was damit ökonomisch
einhergeht hohe teurerung steigende
Zinsen riesige Schuldenberge an immer
größer werdende Kluft zwischen Arm und
Reich eine Vielzahl von Problemen die
noch gar nicht alle genannt sind
überschattet dass diesjährige
Weltwirtschaftsforum zum Krisengipfel in
den Schweizer Alpen ist im Laufe des
Tages die globale Elite aus Politik und
Wirtschaft angereist Motto
Zusammenarbeit in einer fragmentierten
in einer zersplitterten Welt so gut das
Motto so groß die Sorge ob das Forum
überhaupt noch der richtige Ort ist um
die aktuellen Probleme zu lösen
warum welche kritik gibt es da naja
unumstritten war das Treffen nie
Kritiker schimpfen viele viele
Entwicklungen des Kapitalismus lassen
sich in Davos mustergültig studieren die
hohen Übernachtungspreise oder die
Schäden für Umwelt und Natur
beispielsweise doch abgesehen von den
äußeren Umständen hat sich eben auch die
Welt verändert die internationale
Ordnung für die da wo es jahrzehntelang
stand zerfällt gerade und mit ihr die
Überzeugung dass die Globalisierung in
der jetzigen Form noch eine Zukunft hat
andererseits und das muss man auch sagen
es ist natürlich immer gut miteinander
zu reden gerade in schwierigen Zeiten
Frank Bethmann vielen Dank
ARD und ZDF werden weiterhin ausführlich
von olympischen Sommer- und
Winterspielen Berichten im Fernsehen
sowie online beide
öffentlich-rechtlichen Sender erhielten
die über Olympia Übertragungsrechte von
2026 bis 2230
sie war Kino Ikone photojournalistin
Bildhauerin UN-Botschafterin nun ist die
Italienerin Gina Lollobrigida gestorben
ihr zufällig kam la Lollo wie ihre Fans
sie nannten zum Film spielte in
europäischen Kinoproduktionen mit und
eroberte in den 50er Jahren Hollywood
insgesamt drehte die Italienerin mehr
als 60 Filme später wandte sie sich
ihren anderen Passionen zu sie war
gefragt der Fotografin und bildende
Künstlerin engagierte sich politisch und
sozial Gina Lollobrigida wurde 95 Jahre
alt
die Telekom schafft ihre Telefonzellen
ab die Post das Telegramm und bei
Vodafone gibt es ab morgen keine MMS
mehr nicht zu verwechseln mit SMS Simson
kann man weiterhin auch wenn jüngere das
kaum noch nutzen am ehesten noch um mit
Eltern oder Großeltern zu kommunizieren
Technik ändert sich Nutzungsverhalten
ändert sich manchmal sehr rasant Corona
hat ja beispielsweise die Videokonferenz
zum Massenphänomen gemacht und damit
vielerorts die Arbeitsstrukturen
nachhaltig verändert über die Pandemie
hinaus
das wirft die Frage auf was von dem was
heute modern ist morgen altertümlich
sein wird
Christian von Rechenberg und malte von
Malzahn wagen einen Blick in die Zukunft
sie schienen für die Ewigkeit gebaut und
hielt noch fast so lange gut 100 Jahre
kommunizierten wir in Telefonzellen noch
länger sogar mit dem Telegramm
manch Handy landete schneller im Museum
und auch der legendäre MMS-Dienst sagt
leise Servus nach kurzen 20 Jahren
tatsächlich sind die Zyklen in denen
Dinge veralten werden immer kürzer also
die Medien die Formen die Geräte fragt
sich also wie lange das noch hält was
wir heute modern nennen Messenger wie
WhatsApp oder Signal liegen dir in 20
Jahren auch im Museum und wie
kommunizieren wir dann
vielleicht so voll digital im Metaversum
wie es Mark Zuckerberg schon plant ein
Ort in dem sich reale und virtuelle Welt
vereinen in der sich Menschen als
Avatare treffen spielen Einkaufen
arbeiten leben
realistisch also man merkt der Mensch
der menschliche Körper der menschliche
Geist ist dafür noch nicht ganz gebaut
und man darf ja auch die Sinnfrage
stellen für 20 Minuten sogar maximal
eine Stunde ist das Ganze interessant
wenn man das mal länger macht und ich
habe das gemacht dann ich drücke es mal
so profan aus und bratzelst einem
einfach das hier raus
längerfristig vermutlich aber dass die
die Entwicklung dahingehend wird dass
wir wirklich solche gemischten
Realitäten haben werden wo wir also
wieder in der normalen physischen Welt
agieren und unterwegs sind und nur
zusätzliche Informationen eingespielt
bekommen und zwar mit Hilfe solcher
Brillen die Technik nennt sich Augmented
Reality und ist schon relativ weit sie
könnte theoretisch das Handy als
Hardware komplett ablösen Gesten genügen
oder Sprachbefehle zum Beispiel also
durchaus vorstellbar dass man in Zukunft
ein Gerät hat wo man eben sozusagen sein
Handy Bildschirm auf jegliche
Oberflächen projizieren kann Glas sein
eine Tisch sein auf die eigene Hand oder
wo auch immer und dann dort damit Inter
verlieren kann die fremde Stadt wäre
dank allseitiger Hinweise gar nicht mehr
so fremd man wäre vielleicht nonstop mit
der Umgebung und seinen Kontakten
vernetzt das kann auch nerven Antworten
wann ich will Privatsphäre gewährleisten
dazu nutzt man besser die klassische
Messenger App
dementsprechend denke ich dass diese Art
der
asynchronenkommunikation und
insbesondere auch sowas wie Text zu
verschicken auf jeden Fall auf absehbare
Zeit erhalten bleiben wird natürlich
wird dann einfach nur die Software sich
bewegen also dann jetzt vom Mobiltelefon
und dann wahrscheinlich auf die Brille
oder auf die SmartWatch die Apps haben
also mehr Zukunft als man denkt
vielleicht nicht alle und vielleicht
laufen nicht alle auf Handys aber sie
lassen uns wenigstens etwas Kontrolle
über die Kommunikation und das ist ja
beinahe modern
das war es von uns vielleicht nach dem
Wetter geht es mit dem ZDF montagskino
weiter und um 0 Uhr meldet sich dann
Gundula Gause mit unserem heute-update
auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend während tief Gero morgen
schon Richtung Süd Skandinavien abzieht
kommt das neue tief harto und zieht
einmal über die Alpen hinweg und bringt
besonders den Wintersportgebieten
Erholung nämlich neu Schnee auch heute
Nacht fällt bei uns in Deutschland
Schnee und Schnee Regen beides sieht
hier weiter in Richtung Nordosten morgen
über Tag lassen die Schnee und Schnee
Regenfälle danach aber im äußersten
Südwesten bemerken wir was von dem
nächsten tief da fällt er nämlich auch
Schnee heute Nacht machen Sie sich also
bitte auf den rutschige Straßen gefasst
die Temperaturen sinken nämlich zu meist
auf plus vier bis minus zwei Grad am
alten Rand wird es noch kälter über neue
Schnee geht es da bis -8 Grad runter und
morgen liegen die Höchsttemperaturen
zwischen 0 Grad in den Mittelgebirgen
Gewitter sonst wird das ein ganz
freundlicher Tag meist trocken nur im
Südwesten da kommt schon das nächste
Tief an bringt Schneeregen und Schnee
vom Schwarzwald bis ins Alkohol aktuell
liegt ja nicht viel Schnee in der Rhön
vielleicht 10 cm 1,50 m finden sich nur
in den Alpen bis morgen Abend aber wird
sich diese Schneedecke etwas ausweiten
sehr große Schneemengen sind dann aber
in den nächsten Tagen nicht zu erwarten
am Mittwoch schneit es hier so ein
bisschen noch im Südosten am Donnerstag
gibt es dann Schneeregen Nordwesten der
Freitag wird dann trocken aber es könnte
tatsächlich bis Samstagabend vielleicht
eine geschlossene Schneedecke in Bayern
geben das müssen wir allerdings noch
abwarten schönen Abend